لقد دخلنا الآن عام ونصف العام في
الوباء ، وهو وقت
كافٍ لبدء النظر إلى الوراء واستخلاص دروس حقيقية
خاصة عند مقارنته
بالنكتة الأخيرة الرائعة للنظام الدولي
، الأزمة المالية العالمية ، هل تعلمنا
أي دروس من عام 2008 هل تعلمنا  تعاملنا مع
هذا
بشكل أفضل للوهلة الأولى ،
يبدو أن المقارنة
تفضل الحاضر حوالي 18 شهرًا من
أزمة عام 2008 ،
ويقول إنه بحلول منتصف عام 2009 ،
كانت البطالة في الولايات المتحدة لا تزال تتصاعد إلى
أعلى أرقامها منذ عقود
كانت سوق الأسهم تكافح للخروج من
واحدة من  أسوأ الانهيارات
في التاريخ كانت حالات حبس الرهن العقاري
تتصاعد
إلى أسوأ مستوياتها على الإطلاق على النقيض من ذلك
اليوم
مع تطعيم نصف السكان ، فإن
معدلات النمو الهادرة تضاهي طفرة ريغان
سوق الأسهم في
مستويات عالية جديدة حتى أن الأجور تظهر علامات على
الارتفاع
بينما الولايات المتحدة تقوم بذلك  أفضل من معظم
البلدان الصناعية الكبرى الأخرى
أيضًا
في طريق الانتعاش والسبب الرئيسي
هو أن
الجميع تعلموا المال  sson of 2008
في الانهيارات المنهجية ، تحتاج الحكومات
إلى
إنفاق الأموال بشكل كبير وسريع
وتوفير السيولة ،
كانت أصوات التقشف في
الولايات المتحدة وأوروبا
التي كانت قوية للغاية خلال
أزمة 2008
صامتة إلى حد كبير هذه
المرة حيث تنتهي الأخبار السارة.  في عام
2008 ،
أدرك صانعو السياسة بسرعة
الحاجة إلى تغيير جذري
، حيث كان النظام المالي محفوفًا بالمخاطر وسوء
التنظيم
وغير مستقر في عام 2010 ، بعد عامين فقط ،
سنت الولايات المتحدة
إصلاحات شاملة للبنوك
متطلبات رأس مال أعلى ،
ورافعة مالية أقل ،
واختبارات إجهاد المضاربة ، والتي
ضغطت عليها البنوك بشدة  ضدها
لكن البنوك كانت مخطئة في هذا
الوباء
، فقد كان أداء النظام المالي
جيدًا بشكل ملحوظ ،
وهو شهادة على تلك الإصلاحات على الرغم
من
الإغلاق القريب للاقتصاد العالمي بأكمله في
عام 2020 ، وقد
نجت البنوك في كل مكان تقريبًا من العاصفة
، وذلك لأن البنوك المركزية
دعمتها ولكن أيضًا لأنها كانت جيدة.
بأحرف
كبيرة وأكثر إحكامًا  لقد تم تنظيمها حتى الآن في
الأزمة الحالية
على الرغم من إخفاقاتنا العديدة في
مكافحة المرض ،
فإننا لا نتحدث كثيرًا عن
الإصلاحات الهيكلية
أثناء الوباء الذي شاهدناه حيث
فشلت الحكومات في العديد من البلدان في وظائف الصحة العامة الأساسية
مثل اختبار تتبع الحجر
الصحي والتواصل العام الواضح الذي
تعلمه البعض  واستعادوا عافيتهم
ولكن تم إنقاذ العديد منهم ببساطة من خلال
الوصول المبكر للقاحات ،
ولم يبدأ أي منهم تقريبًا في التساؤل عن كيفية
إعادة تنظيم
بيروقراطيات الصحة العامة الخاصة بهم بشكل حقيقي
للتعلم من البلدان التي حصلت عليها
بالشكل الصحيح ووضع
أطر إجراءات سياسات
جديدة لضمان أداء أفضل أثناء
الوباء القادم
الذي سيأتي بالتأكيد